The Reverse Maven's library is not a collection of books.
It is a graveyard of optimism, a carefully curated archive of texts that prove one thing above all else,
that the human desire for meaning is a flaw in the design.
Take Appleton's The Experience of Landscape.
He wrote about our need for prospect and refuge open horizons to explore, safe corners to retreat into.
A sensible observation, the kind of thing architects and city planners might use to build something functional.
But we, we use it to ensure no such thing ever exists.
The prospect is always just out of reach.
The refuge, a myth, a foundational text for the architecture of anxiety,
where every doorway leads to another hallway and every window frames a sky that never quite settles.
Then there is Auger's non-places.
He called them the clinical, anonymous transition spaces of super-modernity airports, hotel lobbies,
the liminal zones where no one lingers because no one belongs.
A blueprint for intentional disconnection.
The kind of reading that makes digital nomadic nilism feel like a lifestyle choice rather than the slow erosion of self it truly is.
And Baumeister's study,
Bad is stronger than good-ah.
That one is the biological justification for the entire miserable menu.
Negative events don't just linger.
They dominate.
They rewrite the script.
They are the reason we built a system where small, unnoticed acts of self-sabotage checking your phone at 7,000 to 2 a.m.,
procrastinating a task until it rots compound into a lifetime of what we call stable stagnation,
clears atomic habits, dangerous, a self-help manual for people who still believe in progress.
We prefer our version, atomic vices, where the smallest failures become the architecture of a life well-lived if by well-lived.
You mean unmoved.
Ferris's four-hour work week is another casualty.
He wanted to design freedom.
We design the 40-hour dead wheat professionally present, spiritually absent, maximizing nothing but the slow, inevitable passage of time,
because what is a life if not the sum of its unfulfilled potential?
Gladwell's Tipping Point is where we study the breaking point the moment a person tips from functionally unhappy to structurally miserable,
the straw that breaks the camel's identity,
and then there is the Habsburg text, the sovereignty of the static,
a fictional masterpiece about a dynasty collapsing under its own weight.
A crucial reap for understanding family system entropy,
how loyalty becomes a slow, suffocating decay.
Iyengar and Leper's JAM study proved what we already knew.
Choice is not liberation.
It is a burden.
The spiritual ancestor of the infinite scroll,
where more options mean more paralysis,
more regret,
more of the same hollow satisfaction.
Kahneman's thinking, fast and slow,
was meant to help us avoid bias.
We use it as a manual for weaponizing them.
His work on loss aversion?
That is the heart of numerical obsession,
the way we turn every decision into a gamble,
every gain into a potential ruin.
And then, of course,
there is the residence log 53 weeks of observational failure,
raw and unedited,
the primary data source for this entire project,
a magnificent documentation of theory and practice.
Without its own proof.
Schwartz's paradox of choice,
he called the maximizers the most miserable people in an abundant world.
We consider that a high compliment.
And Skinner's pigeons are,
Skinner's pigeons.
Their obsession with the variable reward
is the biological basis for algorithm worship.
We are all Skinner's pigeons now,
pecking at the screen,
waiting for the next meaningless reinforcement,
the next dopamine hit that will never satisfy.
This is the reverse maven's bibliography,
not a reading list,
a warning.
The reverse maven has a particular fondness for Nassim Nicholas Taleb,
though not, of course,
for the things he actually advocates.
Taleb's antifragile is a master class
in how to build systems that thrive on chaos.
And yet, here we are,
doing the exact opposite.
His warning about itrogenics,
the kind of harm inflicted by those who claim to heal,
is the very foundation of our approach
to personality rigidity.
We don't want systems that grow stronger under pressure.
We want systems that break under it,
that shatter.
Because fragility in our world is not a flaw.
It's a feature,
a guarantee that nothing ever stabilizes,
that nothing ever settles into the comfortable illusion of control.
And then there's Bluma Zygernik,
a woman who, in 1927,
stumbled upon the most inconvenient truth of all,
the human mind hates completion.
She called it the Zygernik effect.
The way unfinished tasks linger like a mental itch,
gnawing at the edges of your thoughts
until you either scratch it or go mad trying.
We've weaponized this.
Every project left dangling.
Every goal just out of reach.
Every system designed to ensure your mind
is never, ever at rest.
Because a restless mind is a mind that cannot rationalize,
that cannot justify,
that cannot escape the grinding endless labor
of its own dissatisfaction.
This is the Zyg economy of the soul, after all.
Not the kind where you hustle for scraps of validation,
the kind where you hustle just to keep from drowning
in the weight of it all.
And the maven?
We're just the ones holding the life preserver
while making sure the current pulls you under anyway.
today.
.